bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat hier les
travaux législatifs ont repris en séance
publique avec un débat particulièrement
d'actualité
il s'agissait en effet pour les
sénateurs de débattre des enjeux du
prochain conseil européen qui doit se
tenir le 23 octobre alors que le
parlement slovaque a voté hier contre un
renforcement du fonds européen de
stabilité financière les sénateurs ont
tenté de proposer des solutions pour
sortir de cette crise de la dette
faut-il re capitaliser les banques
faut-il continuer une politique
d'austérité
ou plutôt chercher de nouvelles
perspectives de croissance éléments de
réponse avec ce débat permettez moi de
vous dire mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs et ce n'est pas une formule de
style que nous venons d'assister à un
débat approfondi riches de grande
qualité et que ça présage bien de
l'action de la france lorsque les
parlementaires sont aussi intéressés par
le débat européen et qu'ils ont autant
de compétences pointues sur l'ensemble
des dispositifs à mettre en place
je voudrais pas être trop long dans ma
réponse puisque j'ai cru comprendre que
nous allions un bénéficier d'un débat
ouvert et je vois les mains qui se
lèvent et
j'imagine que nous sommes encore
ensemble pour un monde pour un moment je
voudrais quand même rappeler une ou deux
choses qui ont été dites et que je
voudrais rappeler d'abord ça n'est pas
la monnaie euro qui est en cause et ce
n'est pas l'europe qui est en cause
c'est la crise de la dette souveraine
d'un certain nombre de pays de la zone
euro est la première des choses que nous
devons avoir à l'esprit c'est que depuis
ma jeunesse donc il ya un certain temps
oui on me parle de pays émergents eh
bien nous constatons que ces pays ont
émergé et qu'ils nous ont mis
progressivement dans une situation de
compétition que nous avons laissé faire
et pour laquelle nous n'avons pas mis en
place les armes nécessaires en termes de
compétitivité et pour lutter contre ce
phénomène
beaucoup de démocraties de vieilles
démocraties ont mis en place un système
de dette créant la croissance par la
dette est dans une fuite en avant
jusqu'au jour où la dette n'est plus
soutenable
sous l'impulsion d'une crise
initialement bancaire mais vous le voyez
aujourd'hui une crise qui est une
faillite d'état menaçant deuxième
élément est vous l'avez noté un certain
nombre de votes entre vous lé lan noter
c'est que nous ne sommes pas dans les
mêmes temps le temps du spéculateur est
presque en seconde le temps du politique
il est le temps des débats il est le
temps des peuples souverains
il est le temps des passages par les
parlements et il est donc logique que
lorsque l'on reste dans un système
démocratique morcelé
au niveau des états la réponse
démocratique landes à se faire sentir
le troisième point qui apparaît aussi
c'est que de toute évidence la situation
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons peut
avoir une réponse coordonnée par un
couple qu'on appelle le couple franco
allemand qui n'est pas illégitime
historiquement qui est légitime
économiquement 55% du pib et que
paradoxalement quand le couple franco
allemand ne se réunit pas en lui
reproche de ne pas le faire et quand il
le fait en lui demande comment ça se
fait qu'il n'a pas convoqué les 25
autres pour prendre leur avis dans cette
situation nous trouvons donc
effectivement comme nous le disions et
comme vous l'avez montré dans vos
interventions à la croisée des chemins
pas le droit de reculer l'histoire ne se
rembobine bat pas le droit de rester
immobile et obligé donc d'avancer le
reste est de savoir dans quelle
direction
en franchissant quelles étapes et sur
quels objectifs
madame oren de ces y évoquer par exemple
sur des problèmes le déficit de la
balance commerciale française et le
problème de change mais le déficit de la
balance commerciale n'est pas une face à
lille une fatalité en soi elle et elle
dépend de notre compétitivité
et lorsque nous regardons nous nous
rendons bien compte effectivement que la
chine à déséquilibrer la balance
commerciale en 20 ans de la zone euro de
2500 milliards
comment peut-on avoir laissé faire un
système dans lequel nous nous sommes
livrés à mettre en place et c'est là
l'autre erreur une monnaie unique sans
mettre en place le pilotage économique
de cette monnaie unique et donc si nous
regardons ces photons peu
pour se battre la coulpe et le regretté
pire on peut aussi se dire qu'on va
corriger l'ensemble des éléments oui
l'europe de naïve doivent devenir plus
réaliste et oui l'europe à la monnaie
unique doit se doter d'un outil
économique qui pilote la monnaie unique
et oui on sait aussi que l' équilibre
est l'élément essentiel n'ont pas encore
à cause de mon positionnement politique
mais le juste milieu est effectivement
nécessaire parce que si l'on fait trop
de rigueur on crée de la récession et si
l'on fait trop de générosité et
solidarité ont créé de la dette
et si on allie pas la discipline à la
solidarité
eh bien on a un manquement à l'objectif
la discipline sans la solidarité c'est
la misère pour les peuples mais la
solidarité sans la discipline c'est la
faillite des états et donc il est
indispensable que nous ayons cette
vision double où nous partons à la fois
sur un objectif de croissance
et vous avez raison madame la croissance
doit être obligatoire mais la rigueur
doit être aussi nécessaire comment donc
arriver à a organisé un paquet dans
lequel on puisse effacer ce qu'un
certain nombre d'entre vous ont
justement dénoncé cette impression d'un
décision politique de retards permanents
et l'impression que l'action qui a été
mené est immédiatement détruite par
l'événement qui viennent rendre obsolète
la décision qu'a pourtant était prise à
l'unanimité
oui
la slovaquie n'a pas encore décidé elle
le décide aujourd'hui
alors permettez-moi d'être un brin
optimiste
en l'espace de quelques semaines on est
arrivé à parler de gouvernement
économique européen
on est arrivé presque consensuellement
à parler de taxation pour les
transactions financières on est arrivé
sans être déportés au goulag de parler
de fédéralisme économique
je trouve que déjà dans l'esprit la
construction européenne est en train
d'avancer de manière pas forcément
consensuel mais en tout cas qu'un
certain nombre d'idées ont acquis droit
de cité et que même dans les peuples que
je côtoie et que vous voyez aussi même
s'il ya du populisme qui n'est pas le
populaire et même s'il ya beaucoup
d'euroscepticisme chacun dans ce pays a
bien compris chaque citoyen a compris
que ou bien on avance vers une
organisation économique européenne ou
bien ne seront détruits par les marchés
qui est plus souverain aujourd'hui la
france avec un triple a et qui cherchent
à avoir un gouvernement économique
européen ou la grèce qui se trouve dans
une situation où est une organisation
d'accompagnement oblige le peuple grec à
prendre des mesures sans passer par le
débat démocratique
et alors qu'il n'a pas le choix entre
comme je les ai entendus
la démocratie où l'europe qu'il a le
choix entre l'europe et la misère parce
que si demain la grèce ne vous y trompez
pas sortait de la zone euro eh bien ils
bénéficieraient d'une dévaluation de 40%
et le niveau de vie des grecs seraient
rendus à la misère et donc c'est notre
devoir de solidarité et c'est notre
intérêt
il sera bien moins cher des de la grèce
à rester dans la zone euro et de rester
dans un pacte de croissance que de la
force et ou de la laisser le sur le bord
du chemin il faire son effet de dominos
qui gagne progressivement l'espagne le
portugal et je ne sais quel autre pays
et peut-être le nôtre qui n'est à l'abri
aussi et peut-être aussi l'allemagne qui
n'est pas non plus à l'abri de ce genre
de misère
maintenant que j'ai répondu globalement
je vais avoir difficultés à vous
répondre individuellement on avait
évoqué le problème du le du levier c'est
parce que c'est un levier un levier
c'est la possibilité avec 440 milliards
de pouvoir avoir un fonds
supplémentaires soit parce qu'on l'a sur
des marchés annexes privé soit parce
qu'on l'a parce qu'on crée un mécanisme
particulière qui assimilerait le fonds
européen de stabilité financière un
système bancaire mais on nous reproche
temps d'aller lentement et d'aller dans
la complexité est ce que nous pouvons
pas essayer de faire en sorte que nous
trouvions les solutions dans le cadre de
ce traité de lisbonne et dans le cadre
de ce qui a été décidé le 21 juillet et
qui est passé par tous les parlements
avec quelques fois des difficultés et
regarder la difficulté qui a eu au
bundestag
est ce que vous croyez que il serait
logique de refaire une réforme et de
demander au bundestag maintenant de
reprendre une réforme alors qu'il vient
de voter une réforme que l'on jugerait
immédiatement incomplètes à peine
serait-elle adopté par l'ensemble des
vingt-sept
je crois que dans la période que nous
traversons il nous faut beaucoup de sang
froid et beaucoup de réactivité le sang
froid c'est d'avoir la stabilité de dire
oui nous voulons aller vers une
intégration plus forte
oui nous voulons trouver les mécanismes
de solidarité qu'ils ne fassent pas
qu'une banque parce que il y va de
l'épargnant et de la stabilité monétaire
européenne ni à plus forte raison un
état même si les dirigeants de cet état
ont commis par an antérieurement des
fautes
rappelez-vous lehman brothers le
gouvernement américain considère que la
banque a fauté et que puisqu'elle a
fauté non seulement il faut la laisser
couler mais en même temps ça servira
d'exemple à l'ensemble des autres
banques
et puis la contamination a gagné le
monde
si nous avons aimé lehman brothers nous
allons adoré laborde d'autres
avec de la graisse cet abandon de la
grèce sera l'abandon de tous les pays de
la zone euro puis l'abandon de l'europe
puis la livraison à l'ensemble du marché
spéculatif de l'ensemble des états
démunis par rapport à l'ensemble des
marchés et par rapport aux pays
émergents eh bien oui nous faut cette
rigueur et cette solidarité et lorsque
on parle de lenteur je suis
j'approuve effectivement l'idée que nous
devons accélérer le mouvement et aller
plus loin plus fort et plus loin il faut
pas plus d'europe
il faut mieux d'europe une europe qui
s'est élargie parce que ici tomber le
totalitarisme marxiste est ici tomber
des totalitarismes fasciste et que la
grèce le portugal et l'espagne sont
rentrés dans la démocratie et qu'il
suffisait à notre idée qu'ils rentrent
dans la l'europe pour atterrir la
croissance et puis l'ensemble des pays
de l'est dont on se serait mal vu en
train de leur dire vous avez subi le
totalitarisme pendant des années mais
vous n'êtes pas prêt pour entrer dans
l'europe nous attendrons vous attendrez
encore aux portes de l'europe à la fois
la démocratie la croissance et bien
aujourd'hui nous devons assumer d'avoir
fait ses choix
parce que c'est les choix de la
démocratie et ses choix nous devons les
corriger pour faire en sorte qu
effectivement cette zone euro soit une
zone qui soit un véritable pont d'or de
la zone dollar où du vial et qu'ils
puissent avoir une politique économique
spécifique
l'europe n'a pas à donner aux autres un
modèle à copier mais elle n'a pas à
renier le modèle qu'elle a construit
modèle de solidarité modèle de liberté
audel d'un capitalisme d'entrepreneurs
et non d'un capitalisme de spéculateurs
et donc nous devons mettre en place les
outils nécessaires pour corriger ces
éléments parce qu'il y va non seulement
de l'europe mais en même temps des
valeurs auxquelles nous sommes attachés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
devons effectivement monsieur lambert
défendre la grèce avec le coeur et avec
la raison et monsieur buffet baylet
pardon qui nous a quittés oui les
eurobonds tu quand il la situation sera
stabilisée il sera légitime à ce moment
là de faire converger l'ensemble de nos
économies et l'ensemble de nos
fiscalités et si nos économies et nos
fiscalités convergent et nous si nous
avons un pacte de stabilité
et si nous avons un outil comme un fonds
européen de stabilité si nous avons un
pilotage oui à ce moment là le rebond
est légitime parce qu'il ne dégrade pas
la note des pays qui sont les plus forts
et qu'ils ont le triple à par rapport à
la dette grecque
aujourd'hui de toute évidence c'est
mettre un peu la charrue avant les
boeufs que de proposer de mutualiser une
dette qui n'est pas stabilisée mais dès
que la dette est stabilisé
l'étape suivante peut se mettre en place
l'association vous l'avez dit vous
n'êtes pas anti européen ça tombe bien
moi non plus mais je pense que il n'y a
pas le choix entre le populisme de
droite ou de gauche et le centre de
l'ensemble des gens qui dirait toujours
il faut aller vers plus d'europe
il faut modifier nos outils européens
il faut les rendre plus performants il
faut leur donner du sens il faut que
l'europe se construisent sur une
stabilité économique parce qu'elle est
une stabilité de valeur monsieur young
évoquer le mot de fédéralisme et j'ai
dit que j'irai en déportation avec lui
probablement mais on nous y serons en
bonne compagnie parce qu'il me semble
que un jour jacques chirac avait évoqué
ce mot et je l' ai entendu dire par le
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy
donc à ce moment-là nous discuterons
ensemble dans les terres lointaines et
isolées
du fédéralisme économique enfin le la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui peuvent faire réfléchir à
des outils la taxation sur les
transactions financières ne me faites
pas dire un taux immédiatement on dira
le ministre européen a dit que des
affaires européennes a dit que le taux
pour les taxations financières
c'était celui-là ne faites pas dire non
plus quelle est l'assiette
sauf que aujourd'hui c'est évident que
nous ne sommes pas restreints dans
l'assiette et que en dehors de des
règles européennes qui empêchent le
passage des liquidités et le 30 le libre
échange et bien il n'y a pas de
restriction à la taxation de la
transaction financière sur son assiette
après permettez moi de vous dire que je
pense que si la france seule mettez la
taxe sur les transactions financières
nous aurions un peu l'impression d'être
isolé et nous renoncerions à notre idée
européenne
je ne doute pas que la france de
l'allemagne l'espagne l'italie un
certain nombre de pays soit capable de
le mettre en place avec un taux
suffisamment bas pour que la les
déplacements de nos marchés financiers
ne s'effectue pas sur la réforme
institutionnelle et c'est quoi le
fédéralisme économique
ben c'est déjà que des chefs d'état se
rencontrent deux fois par an insuffisant
c'est que sonné un ecofin qui prennent
plus de pouvoir c'est déjà mieux que il
y à un moment donné un pilotage du fonds
européen de stabilité financière qui en
coordination avec à la bce puisse
intervenir plus rapidement et de manière
indépendante de la décision de chaque
état c'est une étape supplémentaire et
après à terme est bien bien sûr qu'il
faut que cette organisation puisse être
autonome sur des directives politiques
qui sont données de manière consensuelle
par l'ensemble des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de la zone euro
voilà les éléments bien modeste que je
peux répondre à aux questions que vous
m'avez posée vous m'avez dit madame vous
n'avez pas réponse à tout et non
heureusement je n'ai pas réponse à tout
mais j'ai l'intimé conviction que
l'europe est en train de franchir une
étape décisive
on peut imaginer le chaos on peut
imaginer que tout va être détruit peut
imaginer que nos économies seront par
terre et que de propagation en
contamination nous tomberont dans la
récession
on peut aussi imaginer que de ce chaos
né quelque chose de nouveau
une autre europe une europe avec des
frontières une europe qui arrêtent de
septembre et qui s'approfondit une
europe qui retrouve ses valeurs et son
sens une europe qui dit ce qu'est une
économie c'est-à-dire non pas uniquement
des marchés financiers mais aussi un
socle de solidarité et une idée de la
croissance pour créer de l'emploi
je suis persuadé que vous partagez pour
la plupart ma conviction sur l'ensemble
de ses branches est donc le conseil va
intervenir le 23 octobre
je ne doute pas qu'il est l'ardente
obligation de décider et cette
obligation de décider c'est toujours ce
qui a fait avancer l'europe
si on dit d'habitude que l'europe avance
étape par étape et crise par crise avec
la crise que nous venons de subir et que
nous sommes en train de subir nous
pouvons franchir une grande étape est
peut-être nous pouvons la franchir
ensemble
merci monsieur le ministre
nous allons maintenant procéder au débat
interactif et spontané dont la durée
fixée à une heure par la conférence des
présidents
chaque sénateur peut intervenir pendant
2 minutes maximum
s'ils sont sollicités le gouvernement ou
la commission des affaires européennes
pourront répondre
la parole est à monsieur vaugrenard oui
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues j'ai goûté monsieur le
ministre avec beaucoup d'attention vos
propos et sur un certains d'entre eux je
vois pas comment nous pourrions être en
désaccord notamment lorsque vous nous
dites que l'europe et le monde sont un
tournant de leur histoire qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir une discipline
budgétaire indispensable une solidarité
tout autant indispensable que vous
parlez de croissance forte
là où le bât blesse c'est que j'ai le
sentiment que votre discours européen
que l'on peut ici ou là entendre et
comprendre et en total décalage avec la
politique qui est menée aujourd'hui au
niveau de notre pays et je pense que la
crédibilité de la parole française du
coup est mise en cause parce qu'elle ne
correspond pas avec la politique qui est
menée au sein de notre pays quelques
exemples lorsque par exemple vous
choisissez de taxer uniquement les
revenus qui sont supérieures à cent
mille euros à hauteur de 3,7 de 3 2 3%
vous avouerez que c'est quand même très
peu qu'on demande peu à ceux qui ont
beaucoup et beaucoup à ceux qui ont peu
alors que si on compare avec des pays
comme l'angleterre ou son taxer les
revenus à partir de 175000 euros ou
angela merkel en allemagne qui l a
augmenté de quelques et parce qu'il est
passé de 42 à 45 % en instaurant une
tranche supplémentaire d'impôt sur le
revenu là on voit bien que il y à une
solidarité humaine qui s'instaure et qui
est indispensable on peut pas demander
une solidarité entre les pays européens
sans demander à l'intérieur du même pays
et de notre en l'occurrence une
nécessaire solidarité humaine entre ceux
qui ont beaucoup et ceux qui ont très
peu par ailleurs vous avez parlé de
croissance forte
comment on peut on parler de croissance
forte alors qu'on vient d'imposer
aujourd'hui
à ceux qui sont assurés dans les
mutuelles une taxation supplémentaire
qui rapportera 1 milliard d'euros à
l'état et donc une diminution de la
consommation intérieure et donc une
diminution de la croissance
là encore il y as décalage entre ce qui
est dit au niveau européen et la réalité
de ce qui est pratiqué au sein de notre
pays c'est la raison pour laquelle si on
ne change pas de politique
au niveau intérieur sa raison pour
laquelle si ya pas une meilleure
solidarité humaine une meilleure
solidarité territoriale nous n'aurons
pas de crédibilité sur les propos que
nous pourrons faire au niveau européen
parce que le zinc monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole sous vaugrenard j'ai
bien compris la stratégie de votre
question vous m'amenez sur le marché
intérieur si j'ose dire pour me faire
répondre sur le plan européen
alors je vais essayer de le faire et
vous dire simplement que très difficile
de comparer l'ensemble des pays de la
zone euro difficile par exemple de
comparer les retraites allemande des
retraites françaises difficile de
comparer le niveau d'imposition tva qui
peut exister en grande bretagne et en
france
difficile de comparer aussi l'impôt sur
la solidarité français avec d'autres
pays qui ne l'ont pas mise en place et
donc toute comparaison des pays
européens méritent une étude beaucoup
plus pertinente que ce que vous venez
d'évoquer y compris le fait que si vous
regardez le rapport sur les mutuelles
vous vous rendez compte que peut-être
pas tout peut-être par chez chacun mais
beaucoup de mutuelles ont des marges de
manoeuvre très importante et que
peut-être la solidarité serait aussi que
les mutuelles ne soit pas une
accumulation de capital mais où une
redistribution de la solidarité
et quant à savoir qui est riche je me
risquerai pas
le définir ici un jour a eu non candidat
peut-être candidat avait dit que c'était
à partir de 4000 euros par mois et il y
avait une polémique s'en était ensuite
qui avait suivi qui avait été
inextinguible donc je pense que soyons
prudents avant de comparer le niveau
social et de solidarité d'un pays par
rapport à l'autre la france est le pays
qui a trois points de pib de solidarité
de plus que tous les pays de la zone
euro et même devant la suède donc la
réflexion de la pertinence de solidarité
interne n'a rien à envier à l'ensemble
des autres pays de la zone euro essayant
de comparer ce qui est comparable
et si vous voulez on va revenir au débat
européen de solidarité de rigueur qui
aussi le débat français parce que
lorsqu'on fait de la croissance avec des
dépenses d'avenir et en même temps une
rigueur budgétaire
eh bien on obtient effectivement un
triple a et on obtient en même temps des
possibilités pour la recherche et pour
l'emploi et puis lorsque l'on n'applique
effectivement un déficit que l'on
définit à 5,7 et que l' on le fait à 5,7
et qu'il faut trouver un milliard
supplémentaire
eh bien on impose à 87% les entreprises
et les personnes les plus favorisés par
rapport à l'ensemble de la population ce
qui est aussi une marque de solidarité
donc ne m'entraînais pas sur ce débat ce
que je serais obligé d'y répondre et de
manière totalement incomplète et bien
moins compétente que celle que le ferai
françois baroin mais mais sur l'ensemble
des sur l'ensemble des projets européens
gardons à l'esprit l' équilibre de la
rigueur budgétaire et de la solidarité
de la croissance est de
et de la stabilité merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est un monsieur bizet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
j'avais trois questions excessivement
rapide je voudrais revenir sur le
programme d aide aux plus démunis
nous étions permis à la commission des
affaires économiques des affaires
européennes pardon de d'interpeller le
président barroso en juin dernier
il ne nous a toujours pas répondu ce qui
n'est pas convenable alors que dans le
cadre de l'application est bien du
traité de lisbonne le prin de la
commission a trois mois pour nous
répondons qu'il serait temps si vous
voulez que nous ayons une réponse je
sais l'investissement qui est le vôtre
monsieur le ministre ainsi que celui du
ministre de l'agriculture et j'aimerais
savoir où vous en êtes sûr cette
politique est-ce que vous avez levé la
minorité de blocage des six états
membres
deuxième point a trait à la protection
des épargnants et des activités dites à
risque je me réjouis que nous ayons eu
des avancées dans la réglementation
européenne en ce qui concerne le secteur
bancaire au delà de l'incontestable
objectif de stabilisation financière il
s'agit aussi proposé aux épargnants une
forme de protection face aux activités
considérées comme risquées notamment les
activités de trading
où en êtes-vous monsieur min sur la
séparation nette entre les activités
trading pour compte propre et les autres
activités comme cela a été réalisé dans
certains pays anglo saxons enfin le
dernier point à très précisément à la
prothèse au principe de réciprocité et
là je voudrais rebondir sur les propos
notre collègue daniel raoul je le
remercie et je le félicite d'avoir
repris certains extraits du rapport sur
l'om c'est que nous avions rendu près de
la commission des affaires économiques
j'avoue que la commission des affaires
européennes avait à plusieurs reprises
réaliser un rapport sur la préférence
communautaire considérant que depuis le
traité de rome depuis 1957 la préférence
communautaire n'était plus qu'un
principe entre guillemets incantatoire
puisque les règles de commerce
international la règle de l'om c'est à
avait supplanté cette notion de
préférence communautaire
j'avoue que je me réjouis si vous voulez
qu'enfin nous puissions mettre cela en
musique
nous avons cas semblait incertain je
dirais un certain nombre d'éléments du
puzzle que ce soit les clauses de
sauvegarde que ce soit je dirais
l'accord espèces ou les passerelles avec
l'oit et je pense que c'est la bonne
réponse c'est bien plus pertinent que
les théories sur la démondialisation
ce qui prône la démondialisation ou à
mon avis ou bien une méconnaissance
profonde du sujet et ça c'est
pardonnable
ou bien des relents de populisme et ça
c'est plutôt méprisable donc je voudrais
savoir ou en août vous en êtes dans les
négociations avec le le directeur
général de l'om c'est monsieur pascal
lamy pour ma part moi je ne suis pas du
tout favorable je vous le dis très
clairement à ce que nous puissions
conclure le cycle de doha parce que 2001
c'était il ya très longtemps
c'était il ya très longtemps et nous
sommes allés très loin ça je rejoins
daniel razoux raul nous sommes allés
beaucoup trop loin dans les concessions
sur le plan agricole
merci merci cher collègue monsieur le
ministre je prie de m'excuser auprès de
la présidence je n'avais pas la notion
qu'il fallait répondre aux deux minutes
donc je vais répondre en deux minutes
désormais et j'essaierai de pathé passer
mon temps sur le pmad où il est monsieur
disait tu vois
je vais tellement tellement connu au
dessus de la mêlée dans sa présidence et
que je m'étonne de le trouver dans un
coin de l'hémicycle sur le pead est
effectivement la campagne hivernale est
de 2011 est assurée vous le savez dans
ce contexte vous le savez aussi il ya
une situation qui était que c'est les
surplus de la pac qui servait à
alimenter ce fonds pour les plus démunis
et que lorsqu'il n'y a plus de surplus
une décision de justice nous a donné
l'obligation de ne plus acheter des
surplus comme le faisait l'europe
il se trouve que c'est un problème qui à
mon avis plus qu'un problème financier
et économique c'est un problème de
l'image de l'europe
comment dire et on dans le grand public
même si ça n'est pas tout à fait vrai on
peut donner des milliards des banques et
on peut pas donner quelques millions aux
plus pauvres d'entre eux et cette
situation est donc intolérable le
président de la république et le premier
ministre ont donné abri dont le maire
est moi-même mission de trouver des
solutions
je reviens ce matin du luxembourg où
j'ai revu mon homologue tchèque one
homologues allemands et mon homologue
danois puisque vous le savez les danois
ont changé de majorité et peut-être
pourrons-nous nous trouver dans une
situation plus favorable
vous le savez aussi le dernier conseil
recul tueur a essayé de trouver une
solution en faisant deux lignes
budgétaires différentes une solidarité
une agriculture et devant l'échec
probable
bruno le maire a préféré reporter cette
question au 20 octobre
sachez monsieur sénateurs que nous
sommes déterminés à trouver une solution
et que nous trouverons une solution
qu'on ne laissera pas les plus démunis
d'entre nous
sans aides européennes et je suis sûr
que finalement puisque j'ai aussi évoqué
ce problème devant la présidence de
monsieur jean dreuil ce matin qui nous a
réuni un petit déjeuner nous arriverons
à trouver la solution nécessaire pour la
continuité pour les deux ans à venir
après nous trouverons des mécanismes
différents sur le les banques d'affaires
et les banques commerciales pour faire
simple et rapide lorsque lehman brothers
lorsque lehman brothers tombe en même
temps north en bois tombe et nos sound
rock uniquement une banque de prêt est
donc ce n'est pas parce qu'on est
uniquement ou de banques d'affaires ou
une banque de crédit qu'on se trouve
dans une situation plus stable
je reconnais que c'est une un débat et
qu'on peut y réfléchir mais ne croyons
pas qu on est à l'abri sur la
réciprocité effectivement je l'évoqué il
faut un croc commerce loyal je rappelle
que il ya aussi une façon de rendre le
commerce loyal
c'est de mettre une taxe carbone aux
frontières
c'est n'est pas normal non plus qu'on se
trouve dans une situation dans laquelle
on impose à l'ensemble de notre
industrie
sur le plan européen une démarche
vertueuse et que l'on importe des
produits qui ne sont pas dans le même
système la démondialisation franchement
je sais pas je sais pas faire mais j'ai
cru comprendre que ça pouvait au moins
arbitrer entre deux candidats
socialistes
le ministre la parole est à monsieur
bloqué à monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je ne
savais pas que mon prédécesseur
aborderait le sujet que je comptais
abordés mais compte tenu de l'ampleur de
la situation de la gravité de la
situation et du nombre de personnes
concernées à quelques semaines de
l'hiver il m'a semblé utile de réitérer
la question est de vous interroger
manière plus précise nous sommes donc à
quelques jours du 20 octobre
vous l'avez évoqué date à laquelle
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
rencontrera ses homologues des pays de
l'union européenne le contexte européen
évoqué longuement cet après-midi et bien
sûr marqué par une crise économique et
financière très sévère qui plonge et
millions d'européens dans les affres de
la pauvreté
cette situation s'annonce plus grave
encore donc suite à la décision de six
pays l'union européenne de réduire de
plus de 70% l'aide alimentaire européen
distribués aux plus démunis en ce qui
concerne notre pays
le secours populaire français estime que
4 millions 800 mille repas risque de ne
pas être distribué à partir de 2012
si le psd faisait défaut sur les 700
tonnes de denrées récupérées chaque mois
21 % proviennent du psd
cette décision inacceptable si elle
s'appliquait reviendrait en quelque
sorte à imposer une double peine à nos
concitoyens qui subissent déjà les
effets de la crise que la concurrence
libre et non faussée gravé au coeur des
traités européens ne fait qu'amplifier
monsieur ministre quelles mesures
comptez-vous prendre mesures concrètes
précises détaillées pour faire en sorte
que les plus démunis de nos concitoyens
à quelques semaines de l'hiver qui
s'annonce puisse continuer de compter
sur l'alimentaire de l'union européenne
je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
vous avez entendu mes réponses je vais
essayer de donner des compléments
supplémentaires ces quatre cent mille
tonnes de denrées distribuées à 18
millions de personnes n'est pas rien le
pmad
en même temps c'était de l'ordre de 500
millions est aujourd'hui le surplus ce
pack tourne autour de 113 115 millions
ça veut dire qu'il ya un déficit majeur
de près de 400 millions pour la france
dont le système est assez neutre parce
que donne ce qu'elle récupère ce qu'elle
donne et c'est de l'ordre de 60 à 70
millions la solution la plus simple la
plus simpliste serait de dire on va
nationaliser les led l'aide aux plus
démunis et l'argumentaire de nos voisins
est pas complètement dénué d'intérêt
juridique
si vous prenez l'allemagne qui a fait le
recours devant le tribunal
c'est un pays dans lequel l'aide aux
plus démunis se fait à partir des länder
et donc qui ne se fait pas au niveau
national et donc le bénéfice de cette
redistribution est très différentes
selon les états néanmoins je crois que
nous avons réussi à convaincre
l'ensemble de des pays européens que
l'on pouvait trouver une solution
équilibrée entre deux lignes budgétaires
sur la pac relativement réduite et une
ligne sur la solidarité et donc on a
discuté ce matin défendent cohésion et
de la possibilité d'inclure le pead est
à l'intérieur des fonds de cohésion mais
reste alors de se retrouver dans une
situation qui passent la barrière
juridique de la décision de la justice
et qui en même temps lève la minorité de
blocage vous le savez le minerai de
blocage vient dans cette norme d'état
mais plutôt on espère plutôt faire
infléchir nos amis chez tchèque où nos
amis danois et j'ai un peu plus d'espoir
sur nos amis d'anne hourra que sur nos
amis tchèques
après la matinée que j'ai passé au
luxembourg si monsieur le ministre la
parole est un monsieur de noeuds
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vous avez parlé monsieur le ministre
tout ailleurs de la volatilité des prix
agricoles
il y a trois mois et demi j'étais dans
cette enceinte le rapporteur d'une
résolution qui a été voté à l'unanimité
je vous engagerait à garowe dire mais je
vous renverrai mais c'est pas un objet
principal de mon intervention je
voudrais vous parler du climat et de la
position européenne face au changement
climatique
la prochaine conférence internationale
se tiendra à durban fin novembre cette
conférence s'inscrit dans la continuité
de la conférence de copenhague en 2009
nous étions qui avait consacré une
rupture dans la logique de construction
des négociations internationales pour un
changement climatique puis celle de
cancun l'an dernier qui n'avaient pas
pris position sur le prolongement du
mécanisme de kyoto la france sous
l'impulsion dieu a mené une politique
particulièrement ambitieux en la matière
en effet en 2008 un niveau des gaz à
effet de serre fait nous avait déjà
diminué de 6,4 pour cent par rapport à
90 dans ces conditions à durban il faut
que les grandes économies mondiales se
mobilisent plus fortement le protocole
de kyoto et gossau boutique juridique
contraignant or les nouvelles nations
économique qu'on appelle les bric ont
aussi estimé que la prolongation du
protocole de kyoto au-delà de 2012
serait la priorité numéro un de la
conférence de durban est ce votre avis
il y a eu un conseil européen des
ministres de l'environnement pour
proposer une position commune autour
d'un prolongement du protocole il semble
bien qu'il y ait divergences au sein de
l'italie en hongrie les états membres de
l'europe centrale l'ont fait savoir
notamment sur le traitement du surplus
des unités de quantités attribuées
alors que même si on faisait cela on
serait seulement à 60% des efforts
nécessaires pour que l'augmentation de
température reste à terme intérieur à 2
veille dans ces conditions monsieur le
ministre deux questions si les
engagements actuels sont insuffisants
on regarde du but à atteindre et que
l'europe défende eu un objectif plus
ambitieux de l'émission des gaz à effet
de serre que celui de kyoto est ce
possible
deuxième question agger ou de nouvelles
puissances pointe du doigt des mesures
de l'union européenne tels par exemple
la décision que nous avons prise de nous
avons proposé d'introduire radiation
comme système des quotas
est-ce que l'union européenne qui
traverse une crise financière importante
et dont nous parlons qui domine tout le
reste
l'union européenne est elle en mesure
aujourd'hui d'imposer sa politique
unilatérale de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
haga chine et aux états unis d'amérique
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
vous avez raison nous nous trouvons dans
une situation qui est une situation
difficile d'abord parce que kyoto se
termine qui ne concernait que 16 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et que
l'union européenne ne représentent que
11 % de l'ensemble de des efforts qui
ont été accomplis dans ce contexte
on va d'abord essayer de d'intégrer
cancun est de faire en sorte que les
ébauches de décisions qui ont été prises
sur les fonds verts sur le contrôle des
émissions puissent se concrétiser à
durban est le deuxième point c'est de ne
pas se trouver dans un système dans un
hiatus entre le moment où opio taux se
terminera en 2012 et le moment où nous
n'aurions pas encore pris des décisions
pour des des positions contraignantes et
est admise par tous enfin et vous avez
raison de l'évoquer y le problème des
unités de quantité attribuée si elle
était entièrement reportés signer sur
plus était entièrement report reporter
cela menacerait bien entendu l'intégrité
même de la seconde période est donc sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets
l'attitude de la france est d'essayer de
faire un kyoto 2 c'est-à-dire d'abord
une période de transition qui ne
transige pas avec les décisions qui ont
été prises sur kyoto et qu'ils
permettent l'élaboration d'un système
contraignant et est universel
vous le savez malheureusement beaucoup
de pays n'ont pas adopté ces principes
l'inde le canada le japon la russie les
états unis
donc nous avons encore beaucoup
d'efforts à faire et nous le ferons avec
beaucoup de conviction parce que nous
sommes bien intimement persuadé que les
deux degrés que vous évoquez ni son
c'est un élément vital pour l'ensemble
de la planète
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur châtillon
monsieur le ministre simplement vous
interviewer sur le problème des petites
et moyennes entreprises
on parle de l'europe mais je pense que
nous avons en tant que français à être
beaucoup plus solidaires de nos pme nos
pme qui sont vous le savez les créateurs
d'emplois dans ce pays
2 millions 900 mille entreprises et
quand on regarde les choses par rapport
à l'allemagne
on s'aperçoit d'abord d'une
disproportion entre la taille des ati et
les pme françaises et allemandes
elles sont quatre fois plus importante
en moyenne elles ont une capacité
d'autofinancement deux à trois fois
supérieur il faut donc s'interroger sur
le plan de la rémunération est arrivé un
constat qui était à peu près des
salaires identiques aux 33 euros de
l'heure en revanche au niveau des
charges sociales pesant un différentiel
qui passe 29% à 43 % et donc là on a un
vrai problème d'équité au niveau
européen et d'harmonisation de la
fiscalité
le deuxième point sur lequel je veux
attirer l'attention c'est là les
problèmes de soutien au niveau de la
réglementation communautaire
au niveau du soutien de la
réglementation communautaire toutes les
propositions qui sont formulées sont en
général formulées par nos collègues
allemands et italiens
il y a entre les hauts fonctionnaires
qui sont chargés de défendre et de nous
représenter à bruxelles une non volonté
d'évoquer les sujets avec les syndicats
professionnels de branche et je crois
que c'est une erreur manifeste
nous le constatons les allemands les
italiens ont ce contact quasi permanent
je prends un exemple concret
actuellement une réglementation en
vigueur et je remercie
puisque vous avez fortement accompagné
ce dossier pour les entreprises
une réglementation est en cours les
français l'ont découvert il ya un mois
les allemands étaient informés depuis 18
mois donc là je dis ya une disparité de
traitement qu'il faut vraiment effacer
et demander à ceux qui sont chargés de
représenter la france à bruxelles d'être
un petit peu plus au fait des problèmes
et surtout de les évoquer avec des
syndicats de branche
j'ai été moi-même président d'un
syndicat de branche agroalimentaire j'ai
eu toutes les peines du monde à le cap
de l'ida c'est l'organisation
communautaire a rencontré nos homologues
et donc là je souhaite que véritablement
on puisse apporter un suivi à nos
entreprises
et le troisième point c'est
l'accompagnement au niveau de
l'international
on parle d'exportation je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut parler
d'internationalisation des activités les
allemandes le prouvent du reste et bien
au niveau de l'internationalisation des
activités
il faut que dans les ambassades nous
ayons des jeunes qu'ils puissent
insuffler véritablement d'une volonté de
compétitivité et pouvoir s'intégrer aux
entreprises qui sont censés devoir
défendre celles venant des choix de la
l'effort important doit être fait pour
que nous puissions à la fois accompagné
des jeunes en contrat d'alternance et en
même temps leur permettre de rentrer
dans le tissu actifs en défendant
l'image de nos entreprises
internationales
merci je rappelle que le temps
d'intervention et de deux minutes pour
chaque collègue monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
nous avons la chance de pouvoir échanger
sur ce sujet et j'ai rencontré monsieur
jacob ambassadeur pour l'industrie avec
lequel on à échanger sur ces systèmes
effectivement les pme et c'est la force
économique de l'europe
deux tiers des emplois 60% du chiffre
d'affaires total de l'union européenne
c'est dire que effectivement nous devons
à la fois être très préoccupés par
l'environnement économique et
l'environnement administratif mais aussi
regarder comme vous le dites les
différences qui peut y avoir dans la
force à l'exportation qui a dans notre
industrie par rapport à l'industrie
allemande et qui joue sur notre balance
commerciale
vous le savez le small business act a
été adopté en 2008 sous la présidence
française que il prônait ethnies en
place des mécanismes d'accès aux
financements d'environnement
réglementaire et de facilitation d'accès
au marché sur l'acte pour le marché
unique et sur le marché intérieur sur
lequel travaille michel barnier
nous avons un certain nombre de
protections à mettre en place et un
certain nombre d'incitations parmi les
protections d'abord essayer de diminuer
les contraintes administratives
vous avez été chefs d'entreprises
agroalimentaires et vous avez vécu
combien de temps en temps l'europe peut
devenir pointilleuse voir tatillonne sur
de la réglementation qui n'a rien à voir
avec la défense du consommateur
et puis en même temps révisé les
directives marchés publics pour
permettre d'avoir un meilleur accès des
pme à ces marchés publics enfin vous le
savez le
le comble assouplissement du
fonctionnement des règles communautaires
applicables aux pme est très importante
et nous essayons d'infléchir les
directives dans le domaine du marché
intérieur en particulier pour qu'ils
puissent mieux accéder aux fonds
européens qu'ils puissent se trouver
avec une protection de leurs intérêts
commerciaux par rapport aux concurrences
déloyales dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure et de faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent se trouver avec une souplesse
plus importante pour les petits services
publics organisés par les pm je crois
que nous avons encore et vous avez
raison de porter ce sujet encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire pour
faciliter nos petites et moyennes
entreprises
et puis en même temps les inciter à
faire en sorte qu'elle devienne
exportatrice parce qu'elles n'ont pas le
volume suffisant pour le faire
enfin sur l'information nous avons
encore un des fautes c'est que les
directives européennes sont élaborés
très en amont et que nous devrions faire
participer l'ensemble de nos acteurs
économiques au moment de l'élaboration
de la directive non pas 15 jours avant
qu'elle soit défini et au moment où le
lobbying devient un peu inefficace
vis-à-vis des responsables politiques
que nous sommes c'est monsieur le
ministre la parole est un monsieur
courteau oui merci monsieur le président
la question a déjà été abordé mais
compte tenu de son importance
je veux une nouvelle fois y revenir je
souhaitais en effet attirer votre
attention sur le programme européen
d'aidé aux plus démunis qui permettait
jusqu'à cette année en tout cas
d'apporter une aide alimentaire à 13
millions de citoyens des états membres
je précise qu'il est répartie en france
principalement entre quatre grandes
associations en charge de l'aide
alimentaire les restos du coeur la
banque alimentaire le secours populaire
et la croix rouge pour chaque
association
je vois qu'on ne le dira jamais assez ce
programme représente un apport crucial
et constitue jusqu'à 35 % des denrées
alimentaires distribuées les aides de ce
programme sont donc essentielles à
l'action
association française plus largement et
en tant que composante incontournable de
l'aide alimentaire en france
le pmad est aussi l'un des premiers
supports pour promouvoir l'insertion des
publics en situation de précarité alors
je ne vais pas revenir sur l'arrêt de la
cour de justice européenne
cela a été dix jours appelle simplement
que les associations demandent
instamment au gouvernement de soutenir
et de faire aboutir rapidement une
réforme du programme par la création
d'un dispositif renouvelé et pérenne
inscrivant durablement l'objectif de
sécurité alimentaire des populations
européennes
vous avez déjà répondu à mes collègues
mais moi je vous demande monsieur le
ministre d'être particulièrement
vigilants sur la suite à donner
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
c'est à dire que vous répondre que je
suis en mission avec brio le maire pour
faire aboutir ce dossier et que le
président de la république s'est exprimé
sur le sujet 1
en faisant en sorte qu'il intervienne
lui aussi au plus haut niveau et au
niveau de nos collègues allemands je
vous expliquer les difficultés qu'il ya
de comparaison entre l'aide aux plus
démunis en allemagne et en france
je vous rappelle que le tribunal de
première instance en avril a condamné la
distribution du pead est à partir de
stocks achetés non pas deux sur plus de
la pac et que nous vous avons un budget
donc qui passe de 500 à 113 millions
d'euros en 2012 je répète que la
campagne 2011 est totalement rassuré que
la campagne 2012 et donc l'objet des
négociations et de la tentative que nous
faisons avec bruno le maire pour faire
lever les minorités de blocage
je rappelle qu au dernier conseil des
ministres européennes de l'emploi et des
affaires sociales
la commission européenne a proposé une
révision du règlement du pmad qui est
probablement à mes yeux la solution
puisque il ya une double base juridique
désormais
une qui est une base de la pac c'est
l'article 43 paragraphe 2 et un
renforcement de la cohésion sociale de
l'union qui est l'article 175 paragraphe
3 si on a donc avec ces deux pendants
doit trouver la faille enfin la faille
le passage juridique qui permet de ne
pas acheter des stocks supplémentaires
et d'utiliser le peu de sueur plus sur
la pac et de le compléter avec la
cohésion sociale et la solidarité
je ne doute pas que nous ne puissions
pas arrivé à trouver
j'ai mis trop de négatif vous avez
raison je ne doute pas que nous
arrivions à trouver la solution avec nos
partenaires
de toute façon je ne je ne je n'imagine
pas que nous soyons obligés de dire à la
croix rouge secours populaire et aux
autres que nous n'avons pas les moyens
d'assumer la campagne 2012
2011 c'est fait ce secteur pour 2012
pour 2012 nous nous assumerons voilà et
écoutez je suis trop européen pour ne
pas considérer comme comme comme une
extrémité le fait que ce soit re
nationaliser et non mais de toute façon
hors jeu je n'imagine pas non plus que
le président de la république et le
premier ministre prend prennent une
autre décision que celle que vous
évoquez si nous étions bruno le maire et
moi même en échec
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
richard vous avez la parole
réponse s'agissant du dernier sujet
convient déborde convient d'aborder il
me semble souhaitable pour la qualité la
véracité de notre débat que vous seriez
peut-être un peu plus spécifique sur une
ou deux autres questions dures et en
particulier mentionné celle de la taxe
sur les transactions financières en
rester à des généralités
certes vertueuse mais tout de même un
peu nuageuse
alors que l'on est à huit jours de la
fin du conseil européen me paraît
peut-être un effort qui est encore
perfectible
donc si j'ai bien entendu tout à l'heure
à titre d'illustration
vous avez évoqué un taux qui serait de
0,005 la famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens qui peut peut être être
vous apporter un peu d'être du fait du
changement au danemark sur l'autre
dossier préconise un taux de 0,05 et
vous savez très bien ce qui est en jeu
c'est le caractère dissuasif ou non de
cet axe par rapport aux mouvements
spéculatifs
la faisabilité et l'impact économique de
ce projet a été vérifiée de longue date
et un rapport conclusif a été présenté
au conseil européen il ya maintenant 15
mois
donc il serait me semble-t-il judicieux
quel gouvernement indique ce qu'est
aujourd'hui sa démarche pour arriver à
un résultat c'est à dire que le groupe
de pays qui constituent la cible les
pays qui sont encore en difficulté par
rapport à ce projet et le champ
d'application le choix de l'assiette sur
lequel vous travaillez puisque
aujourd'hui ce sont quand même pas des
questions qui sont ignorés par le
gouvernement je crois aussi que le débat
sur l'utilisation de la ressource qui
seraient produites et quels en seraient
plus significative si on suivait notre
propre proposition est un vrai choix
politique sur lequel le gouvernement a
forcément une position je crois que dans
la situation de faible croissance que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
d'en faire simplement une substitution
par rapport aux recettes actuelles de
l'union au lieu de l'utiliser pour faire
de la croissance et notamment de la
croissance verte en europe est un choix
politique qu'on ne peut qualifier que 2
insuffisant le temps m'interdit de vous
poser d'autres questions sur les titres
de dette
je pense simplement que le refus des
européens qui a été prononcée en commun
par madame merkel et par le président il
ya quelques semaines est une position
d'étape et qu'elle a été elle était
fortement inspiré si j'ose me permette
évocation par des considérations
bilatéral de politique intérieure je
pense donc il faudra que cette question
soit revue enfin puisque vous avez
évoqué le terme de fédéralisme de façon
un peu audacieuse puisqu'il s'agit d'un
mécanisme unanime iter je crois que
avant d'arriver au fédéralisme
il faut s'efforcer de fédérer c'est à
dire bien sûr il faut faire du franco
allemand mais il faut traiter
positivement et attentivement les autres
partenaires européens quand on veut
construire l'accord merci cher collègue
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
vous voulez des chiffres je vais vous en
donner il ya au moins des chiffres qui
sont connues celles la commission la
commission elle propose 0,1 sur les
actions obligataires et sur les produits
dérivés 0,01
je voulais simplement et vous avez
raison illustrer mes propos en disant
que le bon tempo
c'est celui qui à l'assiette la plus
large et le taux le plus bas parce qu'il
est indolore et productif
quelle est l'assiette que nous pouvons
espérer est il raisonnable de penser que
les états unis vont accepter une taxe
sur les transactions financières souvent
ils ont exprimé leur fille de
l'envisager est il logique et se mettait
encore puisque j'ai évoqué trois fois le
juge est une fois devant monsieur von
roll paye une fois sur les perspectives
financières une fois sur le g20 la
taxation des transactions financières
finalement david lidington qui est mon
homologue anglais a fini par réagir et
dire qu'il n'y était pas favorable
nous le savions et donc
à mesure on voit bien que le champ est
européen et peut-être le champ de la
zone euro et puisque vous m'interrogez
et sans que je vous donne une réponse
précise et je ne peux pas le faire
quel est l'objectif de cette de cette
taxe si elle avait été mondiale elle
devait avoir une objets mondiale et donc
on n'aurait pas imaginé qu'elle puisse
alimenter le budget de l'europe si elle
était européenne
on va dire à vingt-sept pourrait
imaginer qu'elles financent une partie
du budget européen
si elle est au sein de la zone euro elle
alimentera forcément alors un objectif
plus limité vous le savez aussi
puisqu'on parle de chiffres en fonction
du taux en fonction de l'assiette en
fonction du volume on peut passer de 20
milliards à 250 milliards j'ai vu des
mêmes des chiffres de 400 milliards si
tout le monde dans le meilleur dans le
meilleur des mondes possibles
toujours est il que il me semble que
plutôt que de 2,2 de pénaliser la
transaction financière dans l'esprit
ce qu'il faut c'est prélevé de manière
indolore pour qu'il n'y ait pas de fuite
d'une place banquière à une autre place
et donc
si je disais le fond de ma pensée je
dirais qu'au début il faut un taux très
bas parce que le plus difficile sera de
faire adhérer le maximum d'états sur ce
dispositif est que puisqu'on en parle
depuis 20 ans plutôt que de mettre la
barre ici il vaudrait mieux quand la
phase peut-être à moins en moins en
moins nombreux que ce qu'on avait
envisagé initialement
peut-être moins haut que ce qu'on avait
espéré mais qu'elle existe et une tasse
qui existe elle peut toujours ensuite
évolué parce qu'on verra que à mes yeux
et je suis sûr que vous partagez mon
avis le taux faibles n'entraînera pas de
déplacement des places boursières c'est
monsieur me posais parole sur le robot
c'était une décision d'étape décision
d'étape ça veut dire que ce n'est pas le
moment mais que ça peut l'être un jour
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
qu'à monsieur béchu merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre le même
si ce n'est pas l'objet de ma question
je partage complètement l'idée que cette
taxe sur les transactions financières le
plus important c'est déjà de mettre un
pied dedans et ensuite neuf dans vont
changer les modalités plutôt que
d'attendre le mieux étant très
clairement dans ce domaine l'ennemi du
bien
ma question porte sur la politique
agricole commune on a parlé de la grèce
on a parlé de la question des dettes
souveraines demain matin le commissaire
ciolos doit dévoiler ce que sont les
intentions de la commission ce qui
concerne le futur de la pac après 2013
or l'agriculture pour notre pays c'est 9
milliards d'euros d'excédent commercial
au moment où on s'interroge sur la
manière de faire face aux conséquences
de la mondialisation dans un certain
nombre de cas nous savons aussi qu'en
termes de lutte contre le changement
climatique
si l'on continue de penser que les
agriculteurs ne sont tes adversaires on
reculera par rapport aux objectifs qu'il
faut qu'on soit capable d'atteindre la
question de l'alimentation de la planète
se pose de manière de plus en plus aiguë
avec un nombre d'habitants qui ne cesse
d'augmenter à l'échelle mondiale et une
surface agricole utile qui diminue
l'agriculture c'est pas une nostalgie
c'est un avenir quand on voit les
chinois acheté 3 millions 800 mille
hectares de terres en afrique on mesure
que la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire
que la question de la qualité sanitaire
de ce que nous mangeons ce sont des
questions qui sont fondamentales si on
ajoute à ça les conséquences en terme
d'aménagement du territoire les éléments
économiques et sociaux qui sont
sous-jacents derrière cette question
puisqu'il y à deux millions de personnes
qui peu ou prou vivent ou travaillent
dans le domaine de l'agriculture de la
sylviculture et de l'agroalimentaire on
mesure à quel point sur cette question
la décision de demain est importante
elle est importante pour qu'on ait une
pac qui soit ambitieuse qui ne relèvent
pas effectivement la politique agricole
commune à une sous politique alors que
c'est là dessus que l'europe s'est
construite elle est importante pour
notre pays dans les règles qui seront
décidées et y compris pour l'emploi
agricole en faisant sans doute en sorte
de privilégier des dotations à l'hectare
qui soit dégressif plutôt qu'un système
qui alimenterait uniquement les gros et
qui risqueraient de détruire une partie
de la haute intensité humaine d'une
agriculture française monsieur le
ministre
ma question est simple dans quel état
d'esprit et le gouvernement à la veille
de cette annonce
et jusqu'où est il prêt à défendre nos
agriculteurs merci cher monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole ce sénateur
état d'esprit déterminée et ça n'est pas
faute de l'avoir dit et répété sur tous
les débats qui sont sur les perspectives
financières
d'abord parce que ça n'est pas un une
politique française c'est une politique
européenne
je dirais même que c'est une politique
communautariser et c'est une des rares
politiques communautarisme ensuite parce
que si nous voulons avoir une
indépendance sur le plan alimentaire et
des produits alimentaires si nous
voulons éviter la volatilité des marchés
dérivés et des marchés agroalimentaires
et si nous voulons avoir une veille
sanitaire efficace
nous devons conserver une politique
agricole commune et forte heureusement
nous sommes pas les seuls à défendre
cette position
un certain nombre de pays
comme par exemple la pologne sont des
pays qui défendent avec nous à la fois
la politique agricole commune et les
deux pays
j'ajoute en même temps que c'est quand
même une politique qui a été évaluée à
quatre reprises ce qui n'est pas le cas
des politiques en matière de recherche
matière de développement en matière de
cohésion
donc il est logique de considérer que la
politique qui a été évaluée qui est
jugée pertinente elle soit stabilisé
alors que la politique qui n'a pas été
qui n'est pas encore passé au crible de
l' expertise peut éventuellement évoluer
je prends la politique de cohésion sur
le territoire même en france je peux
dire que il ya un grand nombre au niveau
européen et en particulier en allemagne
en espagne de territoires qui sont
sortis des objectifs de cohésion
est-ce que cela mérite pas que l'on
réfléchisse à la façon dont on
redistribue ses moyens plutôt que de les
pérenniser un dans un système dans
lequel on considérerait que puisqu'ils
les ont eu une fois même s'ils sont
devenus ensuite plus prospères et tant
mieux
ils doivent les avoirs de toute éternité
donc la réponse est toujours la même
j'ai presque gelé presque par coeur dans
la tête
la france n'acceptera pas un projet
financier une perspective financière qui
ne considèrent pas une stabilité de la
politique agricole commune
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame blonde
voilà merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre
j'avais aussi prévu une question sur le
programme européen d' aide aux plus
démunis bien entendu mais c'est là tout
l'exercice de ce débat spontanée et donc
nous n'avions connaissance ni des
questions des collègues ni véritablement
de la tenue exact de ceux de ce débat
alors vous avez évoqué quelques ce
quelques solutions monsieur le ministre
moi j'aurais peut-être à évoquer avec
vous n'est-il pas possible n'est-il pas
envisageable de prévoir un nouveau
règlement de ce pays a des qui
confirmerait la place de ce programme
dans la politique agricole commune mais
qui le libérerait évidemment du seul
recours aux stocks d'intervention
et puis effectivement la position de la
commission européenne
aujourd'hui et bien d'ancrer le pead est
dans le fond social européen en 2014
alors tout à l'heure vous avez répondu à
mon collègue courteau que effectivement
s'était assuré porte deux mille ans mais
on arrive à la fin et en 2012 et bien
voilà donc ma question serait celle ci
ne pourrait pourrait vous confirmer que
l'état français prendra effectivement la
suite et viendra au secours de ces de
ces personnes les plus démunies
ensuite j'aurais voulu vous poser une
autre question vous nous avez
aimablement invité le conseil des
membres du conseil de l'europe à venir
vous rencontrer et vous avez entendu nos
observations et nos remarques et cette
difficulté de liaison entre les
commission européenne que ce soit celle
du sénat ou celle de l'assemblée
nationale et
notre souhait de pouvoir travailler de
manière plus plus articulé et de voir
aussi reconnaître le travail qui se fait
au sein du conseil de l'europe qui est
évidemment axé sur la démocratie sur les
droits de l'homme et l'état de droit et
qui concerne 47 pays et non pas à 27
mais voilà comment concevez-vous cette
articulation du travail qui est engagée
au niveau du conseil de l'europe
et puis au sein des commissions des deux
assemblées
merci merci chers collègues subissent
vous avez la parole le sénateur j'ai
longtemps été parlementaire et je me
souvenais que lorsqu'un ministre me
donner un conseil sur l'organisation des
parlementaires j'avais vraiment
l'impression qu'il ne se qu'il se mêler
de ce qui ne le regardait pas et donc je
me garderais d'exprimer une opinion sur
ce sujet en sachant que probablement sur
le président et président de l'assemblée
nationale mettrons en oeuvre le moyen
pour que le conseil de l'europe qui
comme l'avait dit regroupe 47 pays et
qui s'occupe de sujets qui sont qu'ils
ont le coeur les sens de la construction
européenne les droits de l'homme la
démocratie puisse avoir une articulation
plus forte et une meilleure visibilité
au niveau des départs du parlement
français mais
mme avait aimablement enfin vous m'avez
aimablement invité et j'irai au conseil
de l'europe parce que je pense que c'est
un grand lieu de la démocratie et du
passage du message européen qui sort de
la politique purement financière voire
fiscale que nous avons l'habitude de
d'évoquer vous m'avez reposer la
question sur le pmad sous une autre
forme et vous m'avez demandé si
effectivement la perspective de 2014
forcément entre 2014 et 2011 il ya 2012
et 2013 sur cette période transitoire
c'est sur cette période transitoire que
nous essayons de faire adopter en
faisant sauter la minorité de blocage
u11 dispositif transitoire qui
permettrait sur deux lignes budgétaires
différentes et équilibrée de faire
fonctionner l'ensemble nous ne pouvons
pas malheureusement comme vous l'avez
évoqué faire revenir la paix a des dents
la pac
parce qu' elle n'est pas communautaire
peuvent ad c'est un surplus constaté
utilisés à des fins de solidarité mais
on ne peut pas créer à l'intérieur de la
pac
parce que ce n'est pas l'objectif
communautaire un élément de solidarité
donc je pense que et il faut pour être
encore plus clair 2011 ces faits 2014
ça sera dans le fonds de solidarité dans
la politique de cohésion 2012-2013 2012
la solution c'est de trouver faire
sauter la minorité de blocage
trouvez les deux lignes budgétaires et
pérenniser donc faire la jonction entre
les deux systèmes
je suis pas premier ministre et je
voudrais pas m'engager à la place de
valérie pécresse ni de noms j'en
voudrais surtout pas remplacer françois
fillon très bien son travail
et comme la décision lui incombe mais je
connais françois fillon je connais le
président de la république et je sais
les paroles qu'il a dit publiquement
je sais la mission qu'il a donnée
à bruno le maire et à moi-même et je ne
doute pas une seconde que si
malheureusement nous n'obtenions pas ce
que nous nous nous essayons d'obtenir
avec volontarisme et acharnement il y
aurait une pérennité de l'aide aux plus
démunis de manière temporaire et
nationalisé merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur bourdin le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais revenir au système bancaire et
aux banques donc en vous parlant de des
capitaux propres et de leurs liquidités
en ce qui concerne leurs capitaux
propres effectivement on ne peut pas
échapper alors recommandé au moins
d'augmenter leurs capitaux propres et
pourquoi tout simplement jusqu alors on
disait voilà il faut que les ressources
propres par rapport aux engagements des
banques soit supérieure à 8% considéré
que c'était bien
sauf que du côté des engagements des
créances des banques
il ya eu des dégradations qui se sont
observés et pire que tout il ya eu des
dégradations qui ont été observés sur
des titres souverains 1 jusqu alors on
considérait que c'était la quasi monnaie
est souverain maintenant non 1
le résultat c'est que quand on fait le
rapport entre les ressources propres et
les engagements n'a plus tout à fait la
même chose il faut rajouter quelque
sorte provisionner les ressources
propres et bien sûr il faut aller vers
une recapitalisation des banques
faire en sorte que le ratio de 8 % de
balles deux là est bien c'est qu'il soit
peut-être supérieur à 9 à 10 j'en sais
rien mais il ya une nécessité d'autant
que avec la crise des dettes qui
continue et bien là là les titres
souverains dans les bilans des banques
vont être de moins en moins le certains
et qu' il va y avoir encore une
dégradation donc c'est très bien
la liquidité maintenant les deux étant
liés parce que le problème que
rencontrent les banques actuellement
c'est plutôt un problème de liquidités
système bancaire est ainsi fait que les
unes et les autres se tiennent par la
barbichette empreinte prête etc
on est dans un système dynamique tout le
monde dépendent de deux autres voiliers
d'un système vivant avec des difficultés
quand ça bloque quelque part eh bien ça
bloque partout il ya un phénomène de
digues qui se produit je me réjouis
qu'on ait pu trouver des solutions à
dexia parce que ça encombre et un tout
petit peu le système jusqu'à l'heure et
est maintenant donc ça va redonner un
peu d'élan mais les banques continuent à
souffrir d'un manque de liquidités alors
comment elles font elles s'adressent
adresse à la bce un remettre des titres
des titres souverains
1 la bce leur donne de la monnaie et
donc salée c'est les approvisionnent etc
mais ça ne peut pas non plus durer
longtemps que la bce soit une sorte de
station d'épuration qui donne de la
bonne menée contre de la mauvaise dette
ou des mauvais titre ça ne peut pas
durer
1 et donc il faut trouver un moyen que
les liquidités entre les banques
puissent circuler mais pour cela il faut
créer de la confiance crée de la
confiance et sans doute y met du sien du
côté des organismes européens et et de
notre pays donc je vous demande monsieur
le ministre comment on peut faire pour
que la liquidité soit assurée entre les
banques pour que la confiance soit
restaurée entre les banques elles mêmes
chers collègues je vous demander de
conclure oui c'est fini merci monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole
ce saint-herblain vous avez parfaitement
raison et vous êtes parfaitement
expliquer le mécanisme le mécanisme de
la liquidité de la solvabilité qui sont
les deux piliers sur lesquels se base la
fiabilité d'une banque qu'il est basée
sur la confiance
une banque ne vit pas isolé à lui dans
un réseau si une banque ne prête pas une
autre banque
si une banque a des difficultés pour
s'approvisionner en dollars elles se
trouvent effectivement dans une
situation de faiblesse et donc les
ratios qui avait été antérieurement
envisager de 8% doivent être aujourd'hui
augmenter puisque nous sommes dans une
situation non pas de stress tests mais
de stress réel et à un niveau que l'on
n'imaginait pas lorsque les stress tests
ont été effectués néanmoins rappelons
que les fonds propres des banques
françaises a augmenté de 50 milliards
dans le premier semestre ce qui veut
dire qu'elles ont déjà anticipé le bal
d'eux mêmes le bel 3 rappelons nous que
l'exposition des banques françaises à la
dette grecque n'est jamais que de dix
milliers enfin je devrais pas dire les
choses pareilles nez et de 10 milliards
d'euros
donc ça veut dire que les banques
françaises sont solides
cependant dexia est un cas très
particulier vous le savez ça fait 20 ans
que dexia un système de liquidité très
très très court terme ou l'empreinte à
très court terme est d'être très bas et
le prêtent à des taux très haut pour une
période très longue
bon tant que l'on est en période de
croissance le système fonctionne
le jour où il y a
un problème de crédit ou de dette
souveraine à ce moment là le système
sans règle ne peut plus fonctionner et
pour autant aussi je veux le dire
l'action que mènent les états belge
luxembourgeois et français dans le
sauvetage de dexia n'est pas de l'argent
perdu
c'est de l'argent dans lequel on crée
une situation pour passer une situation
transitoire ont créé un système dans
lequel on met une dette pourrie que l'on
nettoie moyen ni à long terme et sur le
geek qui sommes un certain nombre de
collectivités territoriales pour lui du
côté français et les épargnants du côté
belge et en même temps rappelons que la
france lorsqu'elle à l'état français
quand ils à prêter de l'argent aux
banques en 2008 il a retrouvé très
rapidement 2 milliards 8 en retour et et
dexia qui était en difficulté à cette
époque là on 2008 et bien le pré qui a
été fait par la france et le
gouvernement à dexia a rapporté à la
france 500 millions d'euros donc ne
croyons pas qu'on est en train de jeter
de l'argent aussi dans les banques on
doit les obligés comme vous venez de le
dire à augmenter leur solvabilité et à
augmenter leurs liquidités et c'est
l'objectif et des mesures qui vont être
prises
effectivement pour donner une stabilité
cette stabilité elle entraîne comme vous
l'avez évoqué la confiance et la
confiance
elle permet à l'argent de tourner entre
les banques est d'être disponible parce
que le vrai problème d'aujourd'hui c'est
que le système tel qu'il est fait que la
banque ne les banques ne se prêtent
moins mais elles prêtent moins aux
entreprises et aux collectivités
et si on se trouve dans une situation
dans laquelle l'entreprise qui marche
bien n'a pas la seule habilitée la
possibilité de s'engager alors qu'elle
s'engage sur un projet cinq est rentable
alors à ce moment là il ya un risque de
récession est donc la capitalisation la
recapitalisation des banques
à partir de leurs fonds propres
principalement est un objectif
indispensable surtout si on considère
que les prêts qui ont été faits et qui
ont été diminués restructurer de la
dette grecque de 21,5 peuvent être
augmentés à ce moment-là ça créera un
stress supplémentaire sur les banques et
elles auront intérêt à avoir une
solvabilité une liquidité plus forte
merci monsieur le ministre et parole
était monsieur dantec
nous aussi monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre donc vous l'avez
dit le conseil européen va évoquer la
négociation de d'urban la crise
climatique reste extrêmement grave et je
crois qu'il faut pas oublier même si
aujourd'hui la crise financière est au
centre des débats que dans les
prochaines décennies des conséquences de
la crise climatique seront aussi
important de voir plus importante plus
négative encore que la crise financière
que nous connaissons
je n'ai pas non plus le temps de revenir
sur le conseil des ministres de
l'environnement qui a eu lieu hier
s'il est quand même pour m'inquiéter du
niveau de divergence qui apparaît
aujourd'hui entre états européens et qui
fragilise évidemment le rôle leader de
l'europe sur la scène internationale sur
ces questions et pour reprendre aussi
les propos de mon collègue tout à
l'heure ne soyons pas trop optimiste sur
les résultats européens eux mêmes en
termes d'émissions de gaz à effet serre
les derniers chiffres de l'année
dernière montre une réelle augmentation
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
europe ce qui là aussi est un résultat
assez inquiétant parce que ce que je
voulais dire c'est que pour pour animer
depuis plusieurs années et elle porte
parole des réseaux mondiaux de
collectivités locales dans cette
négociation internationale jean mesure
évidemment tout là toute la difficulté
la complexité mais je crois que ce qui
va se jouer à durval c'est d'abord la
capacité de restaurer la confiance entre
pays du sud et pays du nord après
l'échec de copenhague et dans ce cadre
la question du financement du fonds vert
décidé à copenhague est confirmée à
cancun qui doit donc aider les pays en
développement à agir dans les domaines à
la fois de l'adaptation et de la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre va être un point clé et les
pays africains vont être extrêmement
attentif sur ce coin et je voudrais lié
ma question aux débats de l'après-midi
sur la taxation financière non pas par
opportunisme mais parce que je crois
profondément que c'est dans notre
capacité de cohérence dans l'ensemble
des régulations des crises
internationales que nous allons trouver
la solution donc eu une question
finalement assez simple à monsieur le
ministre
est ce que vous ne pensez pas finalement
que cette idée de taxation des
transactions financières que nous
écologistes portons depuis plusieurs
décennies on est évidemment heureux
qu'aujourd'hui nos réponses et pas
seulement nos salaires soient au coeur
du débat public
est-ce que là nous n'avons pas
finalement
opportunité pour abonder ce fonds vert
par une partie de cette taxe
c'est une proposition que l'europe
pourrait porter que la france pourrait
aussi porter au g20 qui permettrait
peut-être de construire d'autres
alliances à l'échelle internationale de
recréer de la dynamique dans la
négociation interne je crois qu'il ya là
une opportunité qui correspond aussi à
ce que l'a dit madame prick tout à
l'heure sur l'idée de départ de cette
taxation des transactions financières et
je crois qu'il serait dommage qu'on se
prive de cette opportunité avec une
question annexe qui est si on n'arrive
pas à financer le fonds vert par une
partie de cette taxe
comment vous voyez-vous l'europe demain
en capacité de fournir une partie de ce
fonds vert qui devrait atteindre je vous
le rappelle environ 100 millions de
dollars à échéance de 2020 merci merci
cher collègue monsieur le ministre on va
rêver au meilleur des mondes dans le
meilleur des mondes le bon exemple est
suivie et ne pas pénaliser dans le
meilleur des mondes
l'europe qui fait d'énormes efforts
contre les gaz pour limiter les gaz à
effet de serre et plus récompensé que la
chine ou les états unis qui n'acceptent
pas de rentrer dans une quelconque
protocole dans le meilleur des mondes
lorsque on a une production industrielle
qui est relayée dans d'autres pays et
avec une productivité qui met en danger
notre compétitivité
on trouve des
des schémas et innovant est doublement
minot innovants à la fois parce que on
produit ou en recherche à produire
l'énergie de demain à la fois parce
qu'on protège la planète mais aussi
parce qu'on crée des mécanismes de
recherche et d'innovation qui sont
capable ensuite de s'exporter et de
créer une nouvelle richesse et puis dans
le meilleur des mondes on se trouve
aussi dans la situation où lorsque on a
un problème international et mondial on
a une taxe mondiale et non pas une
contribution de chaque état a la
possibilité de résoudre le problème
mondial
donc je pense que demain il sera évident
qu'il y aura des des perceptions de
d'impôts de taxes au niveau
international il ya eu une taxe sur les
billets d'avion
cela n'a pas empêché les gens de
continuer à prendre l'avion et l ac
réussit à traiter un nombre de cas
important de malades du sida qui était
totalement démuni pour lequel aucun pays
n'avait la capacité même l'europe de
mettre suffisamment de fonds pour lutter
efficacement contre ce fléau
et donc si je reviens au meilleur des
mondes c'est à dire celui que nous
vivons et que nous que nous c'est ici et
maintenant que ça se passe je vous
répondrai que le vrai danger et vous
avez vu que nathalie kosciusko morizet
et l'a défendue
très clairement ce serait de dire il ya
eu kyoto qui auto s'arrête un jour
enfora d'urban avec un kyoto 2 et
pendant l'espace du temps on oublie
cancun et on on laisse tomber kyoto ça
c'est un message désastreux vie a vu des
gens des états pollueurs et vis-à-vis
des états en émergence de développement
là il y aurait un vrai problème est
effectivement il faut dans ce laps de
temps et à d'urban à la fois tenir les
engagements qui ont été pris
antérieurement
et qui feront oublier l'échec de
copenhague et en même temps établir les
bases de quelque chose pour l'avenir
plus contraignant et plus efficace et
puis comme nous ne sommes pas dans le
meilleur des mondes et que c'est ici et
maintenant je pense carrément donné il
faudra que l'europe prenne ses
responsabilités et au lieu de prôner la
bonne nouvelle
lm pose là la mesure vertueuse et c'est
la taxation et les mixer les taxations
aux frontières taxation carbone aux
frontières
il n'est pas normal que là aussi ça n'a
rien à voir avec la réciprocité ou les
échanges commerciaux loyaux ça a à voir
avec le fait de dire j'aime pause avant
l'industrie en économie une contrainte
vertueuse
j'impose ce qui importe à l'intérieur de
l'espace que je veux vertueux les mêmes
règles de vertu nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi ce débat prochain rendez
vous avec à les travaux du sénat cet
après midi à partir de 17h pour un débat
sur la réforme portuaire
très belle journée à tous
plutôt pauvre